El partido socialista premia,
paga
con unas competencias que son exclusivas del estado
a 1 partido que ellos mismos Han calificado de xenófobo
y del depent español,
y que además ni tan siquiera está gobernando
esa comunidad autónoma
para la que exige unas competencias.
Por eso, lo que les preguntamos al partido socialista es
en qué consiste ese pacto,
¿qué es lo que se VA a ceder?
¿Si es que acaso el resto de las comunidades autónomas
no tienen derecho a saber de qué estamos hablando?
Y además,
¿por qué no tienen derecho a conocerlo y a saberlo?
Y además les preguntamos
si ese es el progresismo del que tanto presumen
ceder la inmigración
a quien ellos mismos califican de racistas y xenófobos